[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
April 18th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
think your gen Z co-worker is slacking
off think again some ambitious
20-somethings are trying to knock down
the stereotype that they're lazy and not
into hard work we'll hear from a 25 year
old CEO about that struggle in a moment
but first wsj workplace reporter Lindsey
Ellis joins us Lindsay thank you very
much for being with us hey thanks for
having me so Lindsay why is Gen Z in
particular facing these stereotypes you
know that they're not ambitious and who
is it that has these misconceptions
about them it's a great question so you
see some young workers on platforms like
Tick Tock expressing how they're
pursuing work by setting boundaries
working to live really being focused on
what they do outside of their careers
and when some of these videos go viral
it sets up a narrative that this
generation is not that interested in
pushing themselves or working hard to be
clear it's not just all all viral videos
in surveys in data gen Z workers are
expressing that boundaries are important
to them and at least compared to other
Generations they might be less willing
to go above and beyond a job description
some workers are finding that those
individual reports or that type of data
is being generalized about all of gen Z
workers and some of the ambitious early
career folks are navigating this as they
enter the workplace yeah so what are
they doing to dispel these stereotypes
it's a mix of things so many people I
talk to discussed the long hours that
they are putting in waking up very early
starting work soon after staying late
making sure everything is getting done
and that they're getting a jump on what
they're doing for the next day one
person I talked to in particular really
discussed the importance of taking
initiative and not just doing what was
asked but kind of taking that extra step
and making sure that her colleagues
didn't need to hand hold her from one
thing to the other the other major area
that I've heard about are just gen Z
workers who are really focused on
learning and growing having an eye
toward what's that next certification or
degree that I can get to improve my
skills and better position me for the
next opportunity well one gen zier who
has taken the initiative is 25 year old
Arkansas resident Charo Thomas she
completed High School in three years
earned an engineering degree in three
and a half years and founded a supply
chain software company when she was 18.
Charo thanks so much for being with us
thank you so much for having me Jr so
with regard to the mission of your
company as the CEO and CTO what is your
job entail yeah I mean it's pretty
exciting as the CEO one of the biggest
roles that I have is setting the vision
and direction for the company recruiting
the best talent to make sure that we can
execute on our vision and making sure
that we have the right resources in
terms of capital and support from the
community as the CTO my role is a little
bit different it's really more focused
on making sure our technology is stable
for our customers because we have
operators who are using our technology
day in day out to do their jobs and
making sure that we're able to release
new technology at a faster clip than
ever before seen possible especially in
this industry and yet Chara with all
those accomplishments you've had
experiences where you've had to prove
that you can be both young and ambitious
tell us about that I guess one specific
example is last fall I was at a
breakfast with some of our investors and
they're absolutely incredible investors
but one of the comments that they made
to me was pretty frustrating I think
they they had this impression that gen Z
or younger entrepreneurs were lazier I
think that's one of the biggest
challenges that young entrepreneurs
especially those in gen Z tend to face I
mean it's a tale as old as time you know
a lot of people do have this perception
that gen Z and Millennials are lazy
entitled have everything handed to them
which is just simply not true and I
think we'd be better served if we
support the Next Generation and give
them the resources and tools that they
need to succeed instead of bringing them
down and it's important to make sure
that we're giving people the benefit of
the doubt all right that's Arkansas
resident Charo Thomas with us Charo
thanks so much for being with us thank
you for having me Jay I really
appreciate the opportunity
reporter Lindsey Ellis is back with us
Lindsay this group isn't the first
generation to face these types of
stereotypes you know that they're not
into hard work right yeah as a
millennial I can confirm that gen Z is
certainly not the first generation to
face stereotypes about them when they
enter the workforce years ago when we
all started work all the talk was about
how entitled my generation was and as I
say in the story bosses joked that we
all wanted trophies for everything
stereotypes generationally are a very
established aspect of work besides the
entitled Millennials Gen X Slackers
there definitely are reputations that
follow groups of workers when they start
their careers so how do these younger
workers feel that these stereotypes
could have a negative impact on their
career the
options are one aspect of a complicated
calculation that gen Z workers are
navigating right now think about the age
of these individuals they have spent
much of their careers if not all of
their careers in the post-covid post
lockdowns era of work they have
navigated offices without a lot of
in-person mentorship especially think
about the folks who started their jobs
in 2020 or 2021 it is just another
hurdle that many of these individuals
have had to face but Lindsay this is the
next generation of workers and possibly
people who could be managing older
workers you know who might be guilty of
these preconceived Impressions what's
the lesson here for the older workers I
think one key takeaway here is that
every generation is going to have a
little bit of everything it's not going
to be that all of gen Z wants firm
work-life boundaries and wants to close
their laptops or walk off site at 5 PM
there are individuals in this generation
and every generation who are really
pushing ahead and prioritizing work and
really going above and beyond you know
that said this is a generation that has
entered the workplace with these very
complicated pandemic era factors and you
know I think older workers need to be
aware that many of these younger
professionals have different patterns
when it comes to communication or how
they like to work I was reminded in a
few of these conversations that openness
to really seeing your co-workers for who
they are and what they want probably is
good advice for everybody all right
that's Wall Street Journal workplace
reporter Lindsay Ellis Lindsay thanks so
much for being with us thanks for having
me and that's your money briefing I'm
J.R Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you